えぇええぇえ
髪の毛切りてぇ
あった！何してるの？
今からー
動画を撮るのさ
こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
えーこの家に住んでから
もうどれだけの日が経ったことか
ってかいつ住んだったんだっけここ
2015年の6月だから
もうすぐ３年DA★
えーここに住み始めて
もうすぐ3年になりそうでございます
めちゃくちゃいいっすよ
引っ越さないのは引っ越さないなりの理由があって
今僕はここに居ます
もう本来だったら
もう東京でお仕事が多いんで
東京に引っ越すべきなんですけども
まぁそれをはねのけてでも
僕はここに居たい理由があるのです
まぁほんと大家さんがいい人だし
このお家も広くていいし
まぁ東京もまぁなんやかんや
新幹線で1時間ぐらいで着くし
なんか近所にねご家族の方が
住んでるんですけども
なんかその人からも
なんかお正月に手紙が来たりして
なんかあけましておめでとうございますと
思っているほどうるさくないですって
なんかもっと
迷惑をかけてもいいんですよ
みたいなことまでいただいて
本当にありがたい環境で
動画を撮らせていただいていると
僕は思っております
本当にありがとうございます
ですが
ぼくは
新しい家を
見つけてしまいました
今から行きましょう
はいでは早速入って行きましょう
うわぁーしょー
（あれ俺今うわぁーしょーていった？）
はいもう結構物が入っているんですけど
こんな感じでございます
奥行きがすごいです
どうでしょう
結構奥行きがあるというか
広いんすよね 新しいお家
ちなみにもうね
家具とか色々入れまくったんで
ちょっと今ごちゃごちゃしてるんですけども
あの新しいお家でございます
実はまだまだ部屋があるんで
ちょっと見て行きましょう
もうね何がすごいかって言うとね
ここですよここ
こっからね下が見えるように
なってるんですよ
めちゃくちゃオシャレポイント
後にここが開けれればね
こっからね
なんか下に人がいたら
なんか物をこうブォーンって
できるって言う
なんかもうユーチューバーっていうか
僕にとっちゃ最強のシステムが
完成しています
どんどん行きましょう
ではもう一つの部屋はこちらです
もう家具が勢ぞろい
あーもうごめん
照明とかもう置いてあるんすけど
どうすかこのリッチ感
ソファー
はっはっはっはっは
はっはっはっはっはっは
はっはっはっはっはっはっはっは
はぁ
ぱあぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁん
いい家だ
どうせこのソファー
そしてこのカーテン
なんかこの　この感じよ
テカテカしてるカーテン
なんかオシャレな照明
椅子!
というわけでいかがでしょうか
ここが僕の
新しいお家です
すごいでしょー
はいどうでしょうか
まだ部屋があるんですよ
こっちにもまだ部屋があるんですよ
見て行きましょう
部屋数も多いからすごいんすよね
ここはまだ真っ暗
（カチカチカチ）
ライトつかないですね
いやーもうまだ何にも
置いてない状態なんですけども
カーテンだけすごいキレイなんすよね
あああああああああああ
ぅわぁ　うぅ
はぁはぁはぁはぁ
はぁーはぁーはぁー
はぁー
なんなんだったんだ今のは
パァァァァァン
ヤァ！また会ったね！
うわあああああああああああああああああ
なんなんだよこの家
わけ分かんねぇーよ
お前なんなんだよ！
誰なんだよお前！！！
この家は
あのちょっとネタっぽく
なっちゃったんですけども
この家は
本当にもらいました
まあ賃貸なんですけどね
はいこの家実はですね
あの〜
あのお世話になっている大家さんから
ちょっと相談を受けまして
ってかアドバイスというかなんか
提案みたいなのをいただいて
あのー
もう 一軒
使う？って言われて
いやー正直すごいありがたかったんですよね
そのうまい棒で家も溢れ
人が増え
もうなんかわんやわんやの状態で
まぁあの家も広いっちゃ広いんですけども
もうちょっと
はじめアミューズメントパークの
キャパをオーバーしているなと
思っっている時に
大家さんからありがたいお言葉をいただいて
この家
実は大家さんが昔使っていた
お家でございます
今は全然使っていないみたいなんですけども
だからその家具とか
ちょっとあの僕の僕だったら選べないような
ちょっとセンスのいい感じの家具が
たくさん並んでいて
まぁとりあえず今は
このままなんですけども
あのこのお家を借りることになりました
実質家…
2つ持つです
であの東京にも家あったと思うんですけども
あそこはですね
契約がなんともうすぐ
あと1か月で切れちゃうんで
また東京で住む場所が
僕は無くなってしまいます
まぁでもなんかそれはそれで
また東京に行った時に
なんかどっか知らない
知らないはダメです
知ってる人の家とか泊まったら
いいなと思ってるんで
まぁそれはそれで
なんとかなると思いながら
あの静岡の拠点をもっとデカくするために
この家も借りたので
まぁちょっとどう使うかは
今後を決めていきたいんですけども
はじめしゃちょーのチャンネルを
ちゃんとやりながら
新チャンネルもできればいいなと
思っております
じゃーな